diese tiere sind einzigartig auf der
welt ein pferd ohne halt eine katze mit
menschlichen zellen und eine kuh mit
boten so würden kinderzeichnungen im
wirklichen leben aussehen
der britische designer tom petters hatte
die idee eine welt zu schaffen in der
die fantasie von kindern zur realität
wird die erste zeichnung die ich zum
leben erweckt habe war ein porträt das
doch mein sohn von mir gemalt hat ich
wusste irgendwie schon dass es ziemlich
grotesk werden würde
er malte ziemlich lange daran so dass
ich schon sehen konnte wie es sich zu
diesem schrecklichen bild entwickelte
hier ist also die zeichnungen und so
sieht die echte version aus ich glaube
als meine frau betty ist sah dachte sie
sie hätte die falsche person geheiratet
tom cruise begann mit seinem projekt
things have gone dinge die ich
gezeichnet habe 2015 als seine kinder
dom und r
noch kleiner waren ihre zeichnungen von
tieren monstern autos oder menschen
haben ihn inspiriert mit hilfe digitaler
techniken verwandelte er sie in
überraschende bilder was ich an dem
projekt so besonders finde ist dass es
kinder dazu ermutigt kreativ zu sein
es gibt so viele ablenkungen da draußen
in der welt computerspiele zum beispiel
doch hier geht es nur darum dass kinder
zeichnen einfach auf einem blatt papier
die ideen für die zeichnungen entstanden
oft auf ausflügen rundum stimmten dem
heimatort der familie einem dorf
nordwestlich von london
tom curtis und seine frau haben ihre
kinder ermutigt sich kreativ
auszudrücken
die witzigen bearbeitungen ihres vaters
haben sie dabei motiviert ich finde es
wirklich komisch aber auch cool zu sehen
wie meine zeichnungen zum leben erweckt
werden
wir wussten nicht dass unser vater
unserer eigenen zeichnungen mit
photoshop bearbeitet hat das hat uns
also sehr überrascht was als
familienprojekt begann ging innerhalb
von ein paar jahren um die welt
zuerst waren es nur freunde die ihm die
zeichnungen ihrer kinder schicken von
curtis kreierte aus ihnen seine oft
skurrilen versionen
dann begann er seine vorher nachher
bilder auch auf instagram zu
veröffentlichen
heute erhält von curtis rund 100
zeichnungen im monat von kindern aus
aller welt die sich eine 3d version
wünschen die besten zeichnungen sind die
die wirklich naiv und unschuldig sind
und bei denen man sieht dass ein kind
ganz viel fantasie reingesteckt hat um
diese kreatur zu erschaffen
rund 15 stunden dauert es eine zeichnung
zu verwandeln
tom curtis hat kunst studiert und
arbeitet als kreativdirektorin einer
agentur die bearbeitungen macht er in
seiner freizeit things have gone ist wie
ein hobby für ihn geworden
ich habe zum beispiel dieses auge vom
original foto und platziere es hier neu
auf dem bild dann summe ich hinein damit
ich die details sehen kann und sicher
bin dass es gut passt und dann kann ich
es auch ein bisschen verschieben und so
wird aus einem kaninchen foto ein wesen
aus der fantasiewelt eines kindes auch
wenn seine eigenen söhne langsam zu alt
für das projekt sind dank der
zuwendungen aus der ganzen welt wird tom
hat es auch weiterhin gezeichnete kinder
fantasien spielerisch realität werden
lassen
[Musik]